[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the sea at Lyon has had a facelift one
so minor you hardly notice it just a few
Totten blinds and a few new features
like the traffic jam assist and front
assist system see I introduced these two
systems in the Atika and now they're
installed in the newly own but the
highlights are in the interior day in
the fungus inside card testa michelle
austyn maka likes how the touch display
replaces a number of buttons and
especially the inductive charging
station her cell phone can't make use of
it but later models can't be charged
without a cable here
the interior seems familiar and
well-structured the materials are higher
quality now ambient lighting provides an
individual flare as is typical in a
station wagon the back seat is rooming
with plenty of legroom but if you take a
look at the exterior you'll notice a few
new design components for example the
angular LED headlights
[Music]
the sideline has been noticeably revised
overall the facelift though minimal
gives the leona sharper more modern look
[Music]
the Leone's trunk holds 587 litres a
simple lever effortlessly folds down the
back seat for more storage space we're
testing the lay on st FR with a 1.8 TSI
gasoline engine it generates 132
kilowatts for a top speed of 226
kilometers an hour and pushes the car to
one hundred and seven point eight
seconds this variant can be had for a
little more than 26,000 euros in Germany
sadly on Michelle says the sea at Lyon
drives very comfortably but despite the
formula racing equipment it doesn't feel
very sporty the ancient does have enough
power to make curvy roads fun to drive
though fr is the name for the equipment
line it means little more than a sporty
look to attract drivers to company cars
say it offers a new equipment package
called excellence for a more elegant
luxurious interior
[Music]
I listen I overall the revised that Leon
cuts a good figure says Michelle the
manufacturer has merely freshened up the
exterior and interior of it without
sacrificing charm shall fail yet the new
layout comes in four variants and offers
a choice of three gasoline and three
diesel engines
[Music]
in Lapland practically every household
owns a snowmobile that's because polar
winters are long and snowy and besides
snowmobiles are so much fun
abba lunch but our cart estimate is
correct says snowmobiles have some
downsides 241 you're always out in the
cold and second you're stuck to driving
on snow anything else will ruin the
snowmobiles runners the all-wheel-drive
Porsche Macan in contrast is much more
versatile it's now available in an even
more powerful version namely with the
macan turbo performance package the
makan was launched in 2014 and since
established itself as a sporty compact
SUV over 200,000 units have sold since
then our test car is the even more
powerful porsche makan with the
performance package though kolkata says
the difference is not so great between
the regular makan turbo and the macan
turbo with the performance package the
german engineers have mainly enhanced
the cars output the v6 engine now has an
output of 324 kilowatts that's 30
kilowatts more than in the regular macan
turbo
you
[Music]
in addition it comes with a super-sized
freak system and the Mekons GTS
suspension PSM and PTM drive asus
systems are standard features in this
makan turbo they make driving on winter
erodes extra safe and enjoyable the
vocal qantas as you can see just how
effective Porsches traction management
or PTM works on this slight incline
there are several options first montes
will activate Porsches regular Stability
management or PSN nirmalam PSN Moslems
debilitates management anger cited in
the PTM the all-wheel drive is
configured as a controlled hang on
system if the rear wheels start spinning
more power is distributed to the front
by a greater engagement of the
multi-plate clutch aladin montes knows
that you can turn off the stability
management outside this reduces the
vehicle's traction on inclines known at
the top Stability management is
activated below traction management has
been disabled
Oh Dada it's also possible to set the
Porsche to off-road mode says Montes
this elevates the car somewhat this mode
also allows variable distribution of
drive force between front and rear axles
making it easier to take inclines it's
obviously silly to do this at full speed
but not just thinks that's the best way
to test the system sorry Abba via
testing hypotheses team-best are made
for das next challenge the slalom course
foot in slalom mattos will set the
stability management to sport mode for
this challenge otherwise it will break
too much when sliding and sliding is
half the fun what's will come about
don't you decide so and here's Equinox
yesterday this instrument shows you
quite nicely just how intelligently the
all-wheel-drive distributes power
between front and back that's high
[Music]
other day McConville Montes says the
macan turbo with the performance package
is plenty of fun to drive on snow and
ice but he's also extremely tempted to
hop back onto this sporty snowmobile
given that ease and snowy Lapland When
in Rome or in wintry Finland rather
BMW has completely revamped its mini
family after three door five door
convertible and Club man model Steelers
will receive the new country man in
early 2017 in 2010 the countryman
allowed the mini to enter the compact
SUV class the new countrymen will be
available in cooper cooper d and SD
editions prices for the 100 kilowatt
countryman cooper without all-wheel
drive started twenty six thousand five
hundred euros to kick off the new year
mazda is now offering its convertible
two-seater mx-5 with an electric roof
system the hardtop opens in 13 seconds
but only at speeds of up to ten
kilometers an hour the entry-level
engine for the mx-5 RF is the skyactiv-g
160 with 118 kilowatts of power it
consumes 6.9 litres of fuel per 100
kilometers the basic version costs just
under thirty thousand euros in Germany
[Music]
that's me clean the mid-range segment is
very competitive says cartas Terry
Manuel Schaefer especially the station
wagons many renowned German
manufacturers offer such a vehicle like
the audi a4 BMW 3-series opals insignia
the Ford Mondeo and so forth that makes
it tough for foreign brands like the
Toyota Avensis last year sales of the
Avensis didn't even reach 4,000 in
Germany compare that with VW what you
can sell that many cars in two weeks so
the question is whether the Toyota
Avensis is rightly avoided or an insider
tip I'm partially odessa's flesh I'm von
wangenheim tip a car's design is a
matter of taste and beauty is in the eye
of the beholder
the toyota avensis turing sports offers
a choice of two gasoline and two diesel
engines we're testing the most powerful
diesel with two liters displacement and
105 kilowatts of power this engine
accelerates the station wagon to 109
point eight seconds top speed is 200
kilometers an hour
the moto venom avensis Amano says Toyota
developed the Avensis engines in
collaboration with BMW but Toyota
doesn't offer an engine with more than
100 10 kilowatts or 150 horsepower
that's where other cars in the segment
like most are just starting out a 130
kilowatt engine used to be offered for
the Avensis but Toyota retired it it was
purchased so rarely that it wasn't worth
producing by apostles Anthony calls
that's just us evolve is google in touch
so the Avensis isn't striving for
sportiness so much as for thrift the
curves on the front make the japanese
car seemed a bit chubby cheek but the
roofline descending to the rear is all
most elegant storage space in the events
of station wagons trunk is between 543
and 1609 litres in comparison the passat
truck holds up to 1,700 80 litres the
ingham Amano has mixed feelings about
the interior some parts are good other's
a bit dis moment always has a hunger fun
here but dirty with the plastic on the
door handle it has all the charm of a
utility vehicle he says thank you but he
finds the instrument cluster very
attractive simple but nice let you know
who you just like the center console
there the Sat Nav and various switches
are all simple but nice the thing in
contrast the controls on the steering
wheel seem thrown together what bothers
Emmanuel the most is the grey on the
gearshift it's not found anywhere else
in the car I'll buy a month Oh down here
there's great too but it's not and it's
found nowhere else in the car either
it's ghastly and doesn't fit with the
rest of the car Romano well the noise
level inside the Avensis seems a little
louder than in most competitors it's not
terribly loud but it could definitely be
quieter especially when you accelerate
beyond 2000 are
emu clearly notice it but the engine
needs those Rebs to really get any power
how about debulk them or two off Omaha
takes off to one so calm nothing's
lacking in the events is when it comes
to safety a pre-collision system lane
departure alert automatic high-beam
assistant and many other systems
simplify and protect the drivers and
passengers lives road sign assist warns
the driver when he exceeds the speed
limit it's all subsumed under the title
safety sense and that standard equipment
and all equipment lines about anything
after spending a day in the Avensis
Amano says he understands why it sells
so poorly the design is polarizing not
everyone likes it apparently most people
don't like it the entry-level price a
bit above twenty four thousand euros in
Germany is lower than most other cars in
the segment but for just one thousand
six hundred euros more you get an Opel
Insignia and for another two thousand
you arrive at the VW passat and both of
them have a much better design and more
storage space making them more practical
for everyday use capacity make offer on
volume on the integration practitioner
for the night attack
[Music]
does this t know yet why naruto is
testing out the new BMW g3 10r with a
one cylinder engine he says this 34
horsepower entry-level model is made for
people who just got their motorcycle
license so he's going for a spin around
Hollywood to see what the bike can do
and he's got company automotive
journalist Stefan Shetty is also testing
out this lean machine on two wheels he
and Reiner get ready to take off
right from the start the bike proves
easy to use
it weighs in at just one hundred sixty
kilos making it nimble and easy to
control an anti-lock braking system
comes as standard improving safety with
the Chi 310 our BMW hopes to open up new
markets worldwide by offering a good
quality bike for a low price
roselyn design by take Brazil says BMWs
Marcus Kemper there a 300cc motorcycle
is a big mid-range bike so we can't
achieve the sales volume with our
current portfolio as with the g3 10r
lets you know the little bike was
developed in munich by the firm's
motorcycle division BMW motorrad let its
assembled in india by partner firm tvs
motor company the bike has a small
headlight fairing with a striking
headlight is proportions are typical for
a roadster beefy at the front and sleek
at the back the motorcycles engine and
suspension are newly developed and
unusually the ancient Sloan cylinder is
tilted to the rear
because I'm 07 says the engines
installed the wrong way around or in
this case the right way so air comes in
at the front and exhaust goes out the
back and the whole thing's tilted
forward slightly that's advantageous as
the center of gravity is lower and
farther forward the swing arms been
lengthened accordingly to 65 centimetres
which improves handling that's 50 hug
the relaxed seating position is supposed
to ensure laid-back and stress-free
driving in both the city and the
countryside
that Papa Medina says the bike feels
good on curves and he can really speed
along it's a typical BMW he's thrilled
by the three tents agility it's good on
curves and on the road what diviner
doesn't like is the lack of power he's
used to writing bigger bikes and feeling
the force of the engine beneath him and
he misses that here Govinda when I
macman wastage VD machine Afonso is on a
craft a ton dust-filled me he envisioned
this is the B&B by Stefan schensul says
it's a BMW he expects a BMW to ride well
and make a good impression of terms of
quality and it does that the bikes light
and extremely agile but never feel small
and wobbly it rides just like you'd
expect a motorbike should it's just a
bit lighter and less powerful than
bigger models mote wat phan most newer
in Lystra own it's the sound from the
performance a truly need to start
physicals
foxy reiners verdict good things come in
small packages it's a nice bike for
beginners personally he'd buy a bigger
one but then he's an experienced writer
this bikes ideal for the city and short
stints but not on long trips VI to cut
the striking is this idea and the
language take it unique the chi 310 are
has a starting price of just under five
thousand euros in Germany due to
problems with a gearbox delivery has
been delayed until the spring hopefully
then customers will receive a motorcycle
that's up to BMWs traditionally high
standards
[Music]
[Music]
it was one of automotive history's odd
men out exploring the Italian Alps and
an eccentric vintage car is a rare
experience the cord 812 looks a bit like
the caffeine fit of a madcap designer or
maybe like a masterpiece by a brilliant
automobile tycoon
ehret Lobban cos current esta christophe
power tells us hardly anyone knows aaron
lobe and cords named today but he was a
shining example of the american dream he
started small as a gas station attendant
and car salesman and worked his way up
to become owner of the auburn and
Duesenberg car makers two of the most
renowned car companies of the time in
1929 he launched a third company named
after himself court automobiles called
ultima files as a young but experienced
entrepreneur Erin Logan cord should have
put the wishes and needs of his
customers first but he didn't he used
the cord automobile to experiment to
build a car that would be new and
different
from an [ __ ] state from the beginning
cord stood out for its striking design
and innovative technologies in 1929
front-wheel drive made its American
debut in the first chord model the l-29
the a12 SC also put the power on the
front axle practically unheard of at the
time but the powerful turbocharged v8
engine quickly pushed the narrow tires
to the limits of their attraction the
cord had trouble handling tight curves
even so it was one of the fastest cars
of its day a garage Adama students
neighs ein auto stab it
with the help of its streamlined body
the cord 812 SC achieved a top speed of
160 km/h the original advertising
brochure boasted that the reduction of
drag was a crucial factor a new concept
at the time like most of the cords
technical components
christoph describes the cord as a dream
for beginning drivers if they happen to
stall the cords ention the driver just
had to step on the clutch and it
automatically started it again and it
shifted with a flick of a finger
tiptoeing through the three gears plus
overdrive semi-automatically and at a
time when few cars even had windshield
wipers the cord had variable speed
wipers it was the first car with a radio
as standard equipment and hidden
headlights in the 1930s that was as
sophisticated as technology gun definite
teach me smooches
[Music]
vasa ain't it what a me knows is
Christophe that's the impression this
court must have made at the time with
its massive wraparound chrome grill the
pop-up headlights and above all these
chromed external pipes that worth forget
comes Andy the car must have seemed like
some bizarre insect from a faraway
galaxy on the statement Gordon blurry a
world famous industrial designer at the
time put little value on understatement
but a lot on elegance and aerodynamics
this was one of the first cars with door
hinges mounted inside so then they'd
always been sticking out looking a bit
chunky the design of the cord was a
perfect dream but only it's designed
kind music in the 1930s the cord 812 and
it's optically identical predecessor the
810 revolutionized American automotive
design with its harmonious and sweeping
lines the three hearts and the logo were
said to stand for e l cords love for his
cars that's easy to believe given the
breathtaking detail of this work of art
on wheels
the fine aluminum dashboard with easily
readable instruments the filigree
shifting gate the many sculpted levers
and dignified club atmosphere show
chords automotive vision extends into
the interior as well the hood is what
gave the cord the nickname coffin nose
and enclosed a v8 engine made by
lycoming one of the leading American
aircraft engine builders normally it put
out some 125 horsepower but this SC
version with the sheets are coming
centrifugal supercharger achieved 170
horsepower and a top speed of 160 km/h
faster than almost any other production
car at the time as soon as a secon wash
pizza the septum was fast konnagar soft
in combination with the superchargers
hum the v8 and its 4.7 liter capacity
produced an unparalleled sound the
chords engine was prone to overheating
the transmission than jumping out of
year and the cooling system to leaking
and it's nearly 1.7 tons proved far less
manageable than the dynamic design made
it appear in just eight years cord had
gone bust
flight record Christophe Bauer concludes
that the cord may have been one of
America's most innovative makes but it
was also certainly one of its most
short-lived even so it was a good 30
years ahead of its time in design
aerodynamics and technology but as so
often with innovators their true value
is often only recognized when it's too
late today it's obvious the cord 812 was
a milestone in automotive history will
be assisted only about 3,000 cord 812 s
were ever built 134 of them are the
coveted supercharged SC version the cord
took its sisters Auburn and Duesenberg
down with it what's left is the beauty
the elegance and the dream
[Music]
[Music]